The human body is a complex place, and our
immune systems are powerful allies.
If you get sick, doctors can often rely on
strengthening what’s already inside you.
But sometimes you need an assist: technology
that can be put inside the body.
Things like biodevices.
[Theme Music]
We’ve all seen a TV show where someone
has a heart attack, only to be revived with a
quick shock to the chest.
Defibrillators are powerful tools, but by
the time a patient needs one, they’re already
in a life-or-death situation.
What if it never had to get to that point?
What if there was a way to catch the problem as it
started and act more quickly than any human could?
This isn’t science fiction:
millions are walking around right now with exactly
that inside their chest, an incredible tool called the
implantable cardioverter-defibrillator, or ICD.
It continuously monitors a person’s heartbeat and
delivers an electrical pulse to restore a normal rhythm
whenever it detects a problem is about to occur.
That’s something a drug, no matter how
sophisticated, could never do.
That’s where medical devices, or biodevices,
come in.
They serve many roles, from rebuilding lost
bodily functions, to managing diseases and
helping you live longer.
It’s a broad category, but some of the most
important are implantable biodevices, like
ICDs and cochlear implants.
A biodevice is implantable if all or part
of it is put inside the body for an extended
period of time.
They might not be easy to spot, but they’re
already in widespread use today.
Around 8% of Americans and 5% of people in developed
countries have used an implantable biodevice of some
sort – that’s millions and millions of people!
Before they could become so common, engineers
had to overcome numerous challenges.
The body’s a complex place, so many biodevices
are, too.
They have to coexist with changing temperatures,
electrical signals, and chemical reactions in a way that
doesn’t disrupt our body’s carefully-balanced systems.
So to design a good biodevice, you need to
acquaint yourself with not only the environment
of the human body,
but also its functionality, structure, and
ongoing processes.
The design process for these devices is similar
to anything else you might make as an engineer.
You need a design that doesn’t just work,
but one that can be manufactured in a safe
and cost-effective way.
But the tolerances can be tiny: a needle that’s a
hair too short might not reach where it needs to go.
A joint that’s too large could cause a lifetime
of pain.
There are a few things you’ll need to pay
special attention to, the first being biocompatibility.
We’ve already talked about biocompatibility in
a previous episode – it’s the idea that not every
material is at home in a living thing.
Not only do you need to use biomaterials, it’s important
to sterilize anything going into the body and you need to
account for the stresses that process demands.
One technique recommended by the CDC is
dry heat sterilization, which bakes the device
at a high heat using moisture-free air.
Baking the device at 160°C for around 2 hours
should do the trick, or you can go to 170°C for
about an hour if you want to speed things up.
If your biomaterial can’t survive that kind of heat,
you’ll need to find a different way to get it clean.
Many biodevices contain tiny computers, so you’ll
need to include a battery to keep it running and maybe
some wifi to communicate with the outside world.
Engineers call these things power and connectivity.
You don’t want your patients to have to
lug around big battery packs or always need
to be hooked up to a cord in the wall.
If you don’t think about power and connectivity
during the design process,
it can lead to a device that’s too impractical,
one that doesn’t work, or one that stops working
soon after you implant it.
A great example of this was the first successfully
implanted electronic pacemaker back in 1958.
Pacemakers use electrical pulses to help the heart
beat more regularly, so it was a big step forward for
patients with abnormal heart rhythms.
However, as revolutionary as this was, the
first implanted device failed after only three hours,
in part because of electronics that were too
bulky and batteries with short, unreliable lives.
Until the advent of more reliable lithium batteries
in the 1970s, failures like this were inherent in the
design of implantable biodevices.
Not to mention that all that water in the
body is pretty bad for electronics, so you
need appropriate packaging, too.
The device should be airtight and watertight
– what engineers call hermetically sealed.
You might be tempted to encase everything in a
metal like titanium, but metal packages don’t just
keep out air and water: they also block radio waves.
If your metal device needs to communicate with
the outside world, it will need an external antenna,
which makes everything more complicated.
A better bet might be to use a ceramic or
glass enclosure like you’d find in a smartphone.
Wireless connectivity helps not only with
device diagnostics, but also with a patient’s
peace of mind.
People want to know their implant is working properly
and it’s far more accessible to have stats on a device
that patients can take with them,
rather than something that can only be
downloaded by the doctor.
Dropping an external antenna also helps
make the overall structural design of the
system smaller and less invasive.
Remember, at the end of the day, whatever
you design is gonna be placed inside a person.
The same goes for your delivery system, or
any medical procedure that you need to do
to implant the device.
Patients are more likely to recover quickly if you
use the least invasive approach practical.
If you can build your device small enough using tools
like nanotechnology, in the future doctors may be able
to deliver it through a simple injection.
Larger implants might be deliverable through
a tiny slit using laparoscopic surgery, which often
enables patients to go home the same day.
If your device is too big to go in through a
small hole, you might run into another problem:
finding enough space inside the body.
If a spot isn’t big enough to fit the whole
thing, or it’s simply better for different parts
of the device to be in different places,
you can design it so that it’s separated
into multiple components.
Take a cochlear implant, for example.
These devices – which can help provide a sense of
sound to people who are profoundly deaf or severely
hard-of-hearing – are often made up of two main parts:
an external portion that fits behind the ear
and one that is surgically placed under the skin.
Even if space wasn’t an issue, it’s much better for
something like a microphone to be on the outside so
that it can more easily pick up sounds from the environment.
Another option might be to remove part of
an organ to make room for your device.
Hip replacements, for instance, replace the
damaged parts of the joint with titanium.
Once you take all of this into account – from
biocompatibility to delivery systems –
you still need to consider device management
and diagnostics from the day you deliver it, to
the second it’s removed from the patient.
Basically, you want to keep an eye on your
device to make sure it’s working correctly.
This can be rudimentary, like having a patient
come into the office to physically get their
implant checked out,
to more modern options, like giving a doctor
the ability to remotely diagnose any issues.
But what if you didn’t need an external
device at all?
That’s the promise of smart tattoos!
Researchers are learning how to put flexible
electronic sensors into temporary tattoos that would be
able to withstand all the twists and bends of daily life.
These sensors – which are thinner than
the hairs on your head –
could monitor the electrical signals
produced by the body, allowing a patient
to monitor heart conditions.
Or, for those with diabetes, the tattoos could
measure blood glucose levels in real time.
The results could appear as a changing color,
right there on the skin!
Tiny tech like this is just the beginning.
Devices that use Micro-Electro-Mechanical
Systems, or MEMS, are the future for active
implantable drug delivery systems.
MEMS enable delivery systems on the micrometer
scale, which doesn’t just make things more compact,
but also allows them to accomplish tasks that
wouldn’t be possible at the macroscopic level.
You’ve probably had your blood pressure
checked by one of those inflatable cuffs that
they put around your arm.
That may work for a simple checkup, but measuring
someone’s blood pressure in that way isn’t always that
easy, especially for people in intensive care.
That’s where MEMS come in!
A new MEMS sensor can monitor blood
pressure directly through the IV line,
enabling continuous measurement and removing
the need for daily calibration and sterilization.
And soon, with MEMS, the idea of tiny robots
inside your body could escape science fiction
and make its way into real life!
One day, they might not only deliver drugs,
but help repair DNA and even restore sight
to the blind.
Once you’ve solved all the problems of getting a
biodevice working well inside someone, there’s just
one issue left: how do you get it out?
Some patients might need the device for the
rest of their lives, but for everyone else, it’s usually
a surgical procedure to take it out.
Well, it’s a surgical procedure for now.
Researchers are focused on developing metallic
materials made from elements like magnesium,
zinc, and iron that are also biodegradable.
These materials could be invaluable in the
electronics of a temporary biodevice.
They’d have the same properties of the devices
made today, but once their job is done, they would
just disappear into the body.
With applications like these, the potential
for biodevices is nearly unlimited.
But it’s gonna take the work of dedicated
engineers to continue to bring those ideas to life.
So today we talked about biodevices and the
part they play in the healthcare world.
We focused on implantable biodevices and all
of the challenges that they face,
including biocompatibility, power and connectivity,
packaging, structural design, delivery systems,
and device management.
Finally, we saw some of the latest research,
like smart tattoos, and just what the future
of biodevices might hold.
I’ll see you next time, when we’ll talk
about genetic engineering.
Crash Course AR Poster
http://www.dftba.com
Crash Course Engineering is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios.
Wanna keep learning?
Check out The Art Assignment where host Sarah Urist Green highlights works, artists, and movements throughout art history, and travels the world exploring local galleries and installations.
Crash Course is a Complexly production and this
episode was filmed in the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney
Studio with the help of these wonderful people.
And our amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.